まだ
実家にいます
谷田部もうすぐ静岡に帰るんねぇ
ちょっとねぇ
やっぱ実況と取りづらいんですよ微笑出すとさ
じいちゃんもばあちゃんの母さんも父さんもみんな怒るんですよ
なんだのでば大吠えてよくないのかな
俺は大声出したら多分伏せ言って帰ってきます
うわぁ家じゃこうなんかすることもできないんだよ
暇すぎてアマゾンで何か買っちゃいましたこれもどうせ怒られるんだよなんかダン
ボールで無駄なゴミ出すなって
じっ狂ってね基本的に何しても怒られるんですよ
まったく住みにくい世の中になったねわーこちらです
あーこれなんか twitter に泣いたこれすごい面白そうっており考え買いまし
た
ボーズ社は競るディスペンサーですわからないんで何かお花花なんかっぽくて
なら a 的にもハナから何株者って出てるっていう
まあね個人的には何が出て欲しいなっちゃう感じなんすよあればでなくても全然なくて
もいいんですよどうせまたこれはね堂で買った時点でまたさ家族からそんな気持ち悪い
もんカールだとか罵倒されるんですよ
こうおーまったくっ
あー気持ち悪いわデイかいい
こんなんす
くっそ
取れなくなってと
小山1回打ったら取れなくなるん
パッケージ駅でお風呂につかっぽいんで
どうなんだろう
なんかまーみーに道を通るときは部屋から出れなっておりてるんですよ
だから
この洗面ずをどうすればいいだろうかもう厳しいんだよいいジャンプなんか
プライドなんか設計を入れれば花川てるみたいなアレです猫
こうやって壁に貼ってこれがお洒落が出るみたいな感じです
あっ
雨ドイツリーグなんとか冷蔵庫がファンとはぐってきました
やっぱ実感何がって言ったらこういうものが隠れる
モノシェアできるのもやっぱりいいんですねここにこのシャンプーとかを入れてこっ
からこう
花たらサンプルが出てこうって言ってるみんなかという感じですね
利益とシャンプーでできるなぁこういうファンとかでも全然
富士山とか入れたことも出ると思うんで
よし
できたうん
を
現在ぞ
レイプでなるん
まあで建てたああそういうことねこういう感じですね
たりて来てね当社どうしたらなぜされるロスとなった
アレアレよだめだって食べちゃナンで食べるのとまってまってさっきは出なかった
じゃんかちょっとこのままやって皆さんこういう音壁とかにね
食べればいいん
肌を花宇これで鼻をくっつけとけばあたりー乱気
ダイバー怒られのコネでこれ価値がわかるやつよああすごい三者で溢れとなかったまえ
ゼンマイと背面ですどうぞ
はあああああ
ran
こえー
のっ
背後へと店
ん
ありがとうございました
のわー
小池栄子ドラからと拡大している
ます
持っていた